CAP how
the British government just gave £1.5 billion of your money
to Ukraine. Imagining that there would be much rejoicing in the land
amongst the people who've just endured a long, cold,
wet and for many hungry winter.
Are supposed to rejoice. Rejoice
that the British government gave away £1.5 billion of their money
to the Zelensky regime in Kiev.
And they're so proud of it.
The Foreign Office website is topped with not make Britain Great,
not Britain First, not we're working for you.
No, it's in a foreign language.
Slava Ukraina. They imagine that
in a country where people choose between heating and eating,
where pensioners are in poverty,
where fuel poverty is everywhere,
where millions of our children are living in official covered
in Britain,
where workers are on low wages suppressed year after year after year,
where prices are rising, where interest rates are crippling,
where energy costs are back breaking the.
In such a country, people will be glad that David Cameron,
Lord Snooty,
the unelected secretary of state for foreign and Commonwealth Affairs
in Britain, gave away all that money that belonged to them.